if you've been on gamespot com recently
you'll know that our expert in the world
of battlefield well it's not jeremy j
because he's pretty much an expert as
well mr. Aaron Samson Aaron how's it
going Danny it's going pretty good how's
it going for you a new dlc drop today
dragon's teeth yeah confirm or not are
there dragons in this DLC there are
teeth of dragons which are actually just
things that stop tanks traditionally
what those big things they had on d-day
on the beaches yeah is big like here
like concrete blocks okay did and
there's not a lot of tanks for them to
stop but okay I don't know like there's
supposed to be a lot of Easter eggs in
this game so it's rumored that there
might be something like a dragon
somewhere that people have to uncover
there was a like John Shaw Megalodon for
the longest time nobody believed there
was a Megalodon in the game and then I
think jackfrags and his crew went
hunting for it and there was totally a
Megalodon in the game alright so what
actually is in this then editor box
you've been playing for a couple of
hours this morning yeah so battlefield
dragon about before dragon's teeth has
four new maps host of new guns um whose
assignments actually get players both
playing within their role and also doing
things that help them play the objective
which is cool because in previous DLC
they've been like a support class go
blow up takes which has nothing to do
with they want to support class totally
and you've been banging that John for a
couple of months now as well yeah so I
was actually really happy to see that
they did that so this is the new there's
four new maps this is chain link mode
which is basically their way of trying
to focus conquest a little bit more the
flag cat points tend to be more aligned
in this mode and you basically get
points i'll just show you real quick you
get points from capturing adjacent flag
okay so if you just get one flag that
doesn't do you any good you're gonna get
the flag and the flag adjacent to it to
bleed tickets and then the more links
that you have in the chain the more
tickets you believe so if you have three
in a row would that be even better than
having say two and two yeah it's
probably works a little bit like
conquest still where you know if you
have half of the links oh my god that I
just love that was just some LEvolution
right there a little bit there's also so
there's that hillside up there there's a
giant mud slide that will come down that
hill
there's a lot of elevated platforms on
these levels there's good verticality if
you are a right I don't really don't
think that was enough I did you know
deploy parachute but your videos if
you're a recon player or an assault
player this is the expansion pack for
you ok now what end because of sniping
lanes or yeah there's just long
sidelines um because it's so infantry
focused you know having your shock
paddles and your health packs and where
your house snacks depending on how far
you are into this game that guys are
really far out there will be good for
you oops there's hella dudes over there
um do go don't worry about health pack a
snack I'm gonna just I'm gonna most
because i'm talking about mostly just
try and support my team here oh dude
yeah get yourself some easy points yeah
pods so these maps are big enough to
support infantry without being
constricting which is one of my main
criticisms I'm getting slide that rut ro
it was one of my big criticisms of the
close quarters expansion from a while
back in battlefield 3 so I think they've
learned their lessons and made these
maps a lot bigger which is really cool
hmm is there a less of a reliance on
transport to get to the battle in this
stuff in in chain-link mode yes yeah
overall yes in they have conquests which
plays exactly like conquest plays you
know tanks and helicopters and vehicles
which I really like you know you find
it's easy enough to get into servers
this early on as well that was a big
problem at all with the first two
expansion packs was that the numbers of
people actually jumping into those and
nice work jumping into those get that
guy playlists was kind of difficult are
you getting enough folks in these ones I
mean anytime day one anytime you have
dlc you divide your community which is
like it's interesting so I've been
having some long conversations with my
friend Ryan schubert about this so I
would rather just be charged more money
like 70 bucks or something and just have
all the dlc baked into battlefield you
know like they should just maybe they
should go to a system where they charge
everybody a little bit more money not
like a painful amount
rather than trying to sell a select few
people you know fifty dollar premium
subscription yeah so that the whole
population who buys battlefield would
have access to these maps and these
modes exactly so then you know your
community isn't divided up there's
always a ton of people and all your
matches are there a ton of people in
matches in like a vanilla battlefield 4
at this point I mean because DLC can
have this effect of like the playerbase
can languish a little bit and yet we'll
sort of drift away to other games but
then the idea with DLC sort of spacing
it out as you then you know you
capitalize on people like oh I haven't
played battlefield in a while oh yeah i
bought premium is I'm I'll get back into
this I'll check out the new maps and so
it sort of spurs just like a
reengagement yeah I mean anything
anytime you have a DLC come out you'll
always get well I mean particularly the
premium players you already paid for
sure you know they're going to be coming
out and playing it you know that the
hard sell is always getting people who
didn't buy premium who aren't hardcore
battlefield fans so two down n do you
think that this pack is actually in
terms of the other parks I know the last
one was kind of disappointed because it
was basically just rehashes of old maps
and why you think with naval strike was
the last one that was actually like as
naval combat goes I was actually very
pleased with naval strike yeah there's
some pretty great mapson um they made
good use of their like PT attack boat
which was really cool and this map is
not a rehash like I who to go Bart this
map is not a rehash like second assault
was which I disrupt the neck just re
strongly with the idea that people were
nostalgic for maps they'd been playing a
month earlier so things are a little
iffy about this expansion pack since
there are things that I like about it
it's weird but after playing the
battlefield hardline beta hmm I feel
like there's it's weird and you go back
to battlefield 4 you kind of understand
what visceral was talking about with
vehicle handling okay also hit markers
and things like that so the vehicle
handling in battlefield hardline beta
was really superb compared to this your
vehicle's alternately feel like you're
stuck in mud or riding on a trampoline
and gore battlefield same with just
general interaction with the ground let
me see if I get around here
so when you're running and when you're
running in battlefield you either a lot
of times feel like you're stuck in mud
getting stopped by like ankle high
barriers there you go Jason point so
like I've you know honestly I'm now
seeing kind of what the you know
visceral was saying about bath of hard
line and their improvements and I'm
seeing it just by kind of going back and
playing core battlefield the ballistic
shield has questionable value at this
stage is that one of the new items for
this yeah so one of the TLC one of the
two new items are the ballistic shield
the other ones actually a battle pick up
the roar bot which so the ballistic
shield is a questionable value in
battlefield hardline the ballistic
shield stayed out all the time it was on
your back giving you protection did
actually act as protection there yeah
was like somebody cosmetic even if you
didn't have it out it was giving you
protection uh-huh and this it's a little
weird like it just kind of pops out of
your butt and then when you are done
with it it just kind of goes back in
there like right it doesn't it's kind of
distracting how it does that it doesn't
necessarily stop enough bullets to to
really be worth your time so like
ideally a ballistic shield would it be
able to eat up at least one entire enemy
magazine because in that case then you
know they would they would light off
their magazine you would then drop your
shield and switch to your primary or
secondary and kill them are you just
talking about like strategy tactics wise
to be valuable it should try it should
you know yeah just the idea ballistic
shield mhm in as it stands right now all
it really does is slow you down and the
person after you will probably still
kill you anyway um so what about the
Roar bought that are a WR cuz that's a
unmet like you you have to park in a
corner and oh no one else noticed
unlucky so r or bought is again it's
like one of those ideas that I feel like
wasn't fully really followed through on
I don't know what I don't know what the
hesitation is to give the engineer class
a robot that can shoot the Royal Rock
condo rise the robot can but it's a
battle pick up okay it's not a piece of
equipment so i od bots in real life
actually do have shotguns in some cases
and the EOD bot just tiny blow torches
yeah and the EOD bot battlefield has
just always been so like useless larious
there's just no point to it what about
the more about in this one what does it
what does it bring anything new
tactically it's got a machine gun you
but you pick it up and if you don't use
it right away you'll probably die before
you get to use it so you pick it up you
find yourself a tube to hide in or
something weird and then you're like
driving this little bot around by typing
forward forward back back right looking
for right yeah just looking for codes or
different words carrots taken over the
world with the robot uh but I also liked
it when I saw it honestly everyone idea
what you die there is God look at you mr
20 times as long as I said I reminded me
of home front to look at it almost
interest in terms of that you know it's
it's sort of robust tackle abilities
that that game's multiplayer was a lot
about drew was a lot about drones um
this battlefield traditionally not so
much but more and more they've been
introducing different types of drones
through DLCs yes so do you think that it
I mean do you think that it has a place
in a map like this is it more of a close
quarter like a closer quarters kind of
situation that you want to use it in no
anyway um I just want them to give it to
the engineer like honestly why can't the
engineer have an EOD bot that shoots
it's fine it's got a shot you've got a
limited range like is it funny lose is
it like when you put it in the field
it's it's cool i mean when you get into
it you the problem isn't that it's not
fun to use the problem is that you would
lose it too quick and it's so you know
it's kind of fragile get i guess you
have to pretty much use it right away or
you risk dying and not being able to use
it again yeah so after your past couple
of hours playing cuz i know totally came
out today what are your initial
impressions traditional Christians are I
recommend this pack for the inventory
focus crowd I think it sets out it
accomplishes what it sets out to do
which is you're like all those guys who
are spending all that time and locker
and metro and those like really tight
inventory maps this is better than that
because it's more spread out and I think
it'll have more mass appeal for infantry
focus combat
it's something that core battlefield
didn't have enough of and I think they
will enjoy that if you're a vehicle guy
and you like flying jets and helicopters
you might not like this as much how many
packs are left now is the second one
more one more yeah have they said what
it is yet what is it final stand okay
that's a good name for your last year's
yeah all right um I gotta say like maybe
it's just me but I'm kind of want to get
back into hardline really I I'm come out
okay after playing this this feels like
it's it's trying to compete with
hardline and I honestly just like the
way a hard-line did it awesome all right
well that maybe you're ready to move on
you're ready for something fresh from
battlefield huh yeah well it's
interesting actually to hear that
somebody who isn't about feels as deep
as you are is actually see something new
and hardline because hitmarkers hard
line so they had markers in the
community test environment here they
were talking about improving their hip
markers but all i gotta do is do what
hardline did alright are blinded better
hit marker so our cheese alright iron
Thomson take very much coming on thank
you
you